[Music]
[Music]
zeus is a wonderful man a forgiving god
a caring father and of course a loyal
deeply loyal husband now some of you may
argue that none of those statements are
true and i'd argue if they were greek
mythology would be a far more boring
place and this video wouldn't exist
today we are taking a look at zeus's
known and lesser known lovers and
affairs at least the more interesting
ones i'm assuming that most of us know
who zeus is by now for those who might
still be unfamiliar he was the king of
gods in greek mythology a wonderful man
a caring father and of course a
what
what do you mean this video is no longer
sponsored by zeus
well why am i saying all of these nice
things if he's no longer paying us
oh
right yeah my bad
as i've just been reliably informed by
the goblins behind the scenes today's
video is in fact sponsored by one dream
for those who have been watching for
some time you will know that the people
behind the great courses plus have
teamed up to create one dream in order
to provide a bigger better and more
immersive educational experience than
before one dream has thousands of
courses lectures documentaries and all
sorts of videos so there's always
something for everyone you can learn in
your own time wherever you please as one
dream can be used on most devices for me
one dream occasionally provides some
video inspiration but most of the time
i'll just watch anything that seems
strange or interesting enough recently i
came across norse mythology a 24-part
lecture given by dr jackson crawford who
is also a great source for all things
norse over here on youtube for someone
looking for a concise well-structured
and entertaining look into norse
mythology this is something i'd highly
recommend
if you'd like to try one dream for
yourself then visit
onedream.com mythology to start your
free trial today
despite being married to hera the
goddess of marriage zeus still part hook
in the occasional affair or two
hundred
thousand
with such an extensive list it seems we
should start at the very beginning
according to hesiod zeus had seven wives
and the first of these was not actually
hera it was metis
metis was the one who supplied a young
zeus with the special potion that caused
cronus to throw up and release all of
zeus's siblings who had been swallowed
and how did zeus repay metis for this
favor well he swallowed her whole gaia
and uranus had prophesied the son of
zeus and metis would one day dethrone
zeus and so having seen the same plan
fail for his father cronus he decided to
do the exact same thing
zeus and metis did however have one
child whom i'm sure you're familiar with
athena was born from zeus's forehead as
a regular birth wasn't possible given
zeus had eaten her mother
his second wife was themis the titan
goddess of law and justice from this
union came the hurai and the morai also
known as the seasons and the fates
wife number three was uranomi another
oceanid who bore the charities three
goddesses also known as the graces the
fourth wife was demeter who bore zeus a
daughter we know as persephone the fifth
wife was nemesin the titan goddess of
memory from this union came the nine
muses wife number six was lito who had
to flee to the island of delos to give
birth to artemis and apollo the last of
the seven wives according to hesiod was
hera the queen of the gods
with the wives out of the way we can
move on to the many affairs and
mistresses
now i am gonna warn you these stories
are weird
very weird
let's begin with the story of dana the
mother of perseus
dana was the daughter of king acrysius
the ruler of argos
the king was extremely frustrated by his
lack of a male heir and so he decided to
seek out the oracle of delphi to inquire
whether he would have a change in
fortune
the answer was a resounding no but she
did tell him that his daughter dana
would have a son she also told him this
son would one day kill him returning
home king acrysius took his daughter and
lopped her up in a subterranean bronze
chamber he decided his daughter would
remain childless if he buried her alive
in a tomb under his palace this chamber
was sealed shut there were no doors or
windows the only source of light and air
coming from a tiny skylight luckily for
dana zeus had taken a liking to her and
a pesky impenetrable underground bunker
wasn't going to get in his way zeus took
the form of golden rain and showered
dana through the skylight impregnating
her so it's fair to say that perseus was
born from a golden shower just not the
type you may be thinking of
the king now just couldn't murder his
daughter and grandchild and so he had
them placed in a barrel and cast out at
sea
the prophecy still came true albeit much
later when perseus accidentally struck
him in the head with a javelin
when zeus tried to seduce hera he
transformed himself into a bird and this
weird process of taking the form of
animals other people and various
miscellaneous forms when interacting
with his potential lovers was common
practice
when he came across europa picking
flowers in a field he appeared as a bull
that smelled of fresh flowers naturally
europa's attention was drawn and when
she hopped on his back zeus jumped into
the sea and swam to the island of crete
zeus then revealed himself and made
europa the first queen of crete two of
their sons radimanthus and minos became
kings of crete
the story of nemesis is one of the more
notoriously strange stories nemesis was
the goddess of divine retribution and
thus not someone you'd wish to anger
unless you were zeus nemesis rejected
zeus's advances and took several
different forms in an attempt to escape
him one form she took was a goose and
this prompted zeus to chase her down
disguised as a swan this time he was
successful in his chase and nemesis
would lay an egg that was then given to
leader the queen of sparta from this egg
would hatch helen of troy some stories
like to switch the position of nemesis
and leader here zeus still in the form
of a swan ran into leaders arms
pretending he was being pursued by an
eagle which was actually just aphrodite
in disguise
some other transformations of note
include a phoenix when appearing to
cassiopeia
eagle when he abducted ganymede a sata a
vulture an ant and a serpent
when zeus appeared to heracles mother
alcamini he did so disguised as her very
own husband although this didn't
necessarily cause her too many issues
with hera it did however doom heracles
to a lifetime of hatred
the titan goddess asteria flew across
the heavens disguised as a quail to try
and escape zeus in the end she dove into
the sea and transformed into the island
of delos
fans of hades and persephone will be
disappointed to know that zeus seduced
persephone on two separate occasions the
first time before her marriage to hades
in the form of a serpent where
persephone gave birth to a god known as
zagreus the second time was during her
reign as queen of the underworld however
this time he appeared as his brother
hades
i did tell you these stories would be
weird
zeus's next lover victim was io a
priestess of hera nonetheless
zeus lusted for io immediately upon
seeing her however hera at this point
kept a close eye on zeus to avoid being
caught zeus transformed the io into a
cow hera couldn't prove that this cow
was one of zeus's lovers but she was
well aware of her husband's trickery she
demanded that zeus gave her this cow as
a gift to which zeus had no real option
but to agree
hera then had the giant argus penipetus
guard the cow argus had over a hundred
eyes making it almost impossible for
zeus to sneak past and transform io back
into a woman
the ever-reliable hermes was sent to
deal with the giant tricking him into a
deep slumber and killing him
zeus then transformed io back into a
woman and set her free in some versions
of the story she remained a cow which
still wasn't enough of a punishment for
hera she also had a gadfly follow aya
around and continually sting her io
would eventually come across a chained
up prometheus who told her that one day
she would return to her human form
we've had some of the more weird stories
but many of these encounters ended in
tragedy the story of callisto definitely
falls into the tragic category the
daughter of king like owen and a
follower of artemis remaining a virgin
was fairly important to callisto as she
wished to remain in the cult of artemis
that didn't last long as zeus came
across callisto in the forest his
advances at first were rejected and so
his plan was to return but in the form
of artemis surely callisto would be
unable to reject the advances of her
patron goddess this time he was
successful and shortly after callisto
fell pregnant with his child the next
time callisto came across artemis she
was invited to bathe with her and her
followers in a river reluctantly
callisto undressed revealing her belly
artemus furious that her vow had been
broken transformed callisto into a bear
so she could never be with her son the
next time they saw each other her son
did not recognize callisto and so they
killed each other not wanting to anger
hera anymore zeus did not intervene when
callisto begged and pleaded to transform
her back into a woman after her death
zeus placed both callisto and her son in
the sky as constellations ursa major and
minor in alternate versions most greek
poets claim that callisto was just slain
by artemis at a later time either way
there is no happy ending for callisto
remaining on the topic of tragedy there
are a few more lovers we can take a look
at lamia was a queen in libya
many would travel thousands of miles
just to admire her beauty zeus had given
lamia two children when hera learned of
the affair she took those children away
some stories say that hera killed those
children and others that she tricked
lamia into killing her own children this
drove lamia insane
hera then transformed her into a monster
and cursed her with insomnia her eyes
could never close
lamia became a monster who snatched away
children and devoured them a story that
parents would tell children to ensure
they stayed inside
zeus eventually found lamia and gave her
the ability to remove her eyes allowing
her to finally rest
semeli was a priestess of zeus he
observed sacrificing a bull at his altar
as these stories go he fell in love and
before not too long she was carrying his
child
hera once again observing this affair
came up with a new way to punish this
lover she took the form of an elderly
woman appearing to semly and befriending
her semilly excited to finally tell
someone told the elderly woman that the
father of her child was indeed zeus hera
pretended to not believe her how could
she possibly know zeus was the father of
her child if she had never seen his true
form
the doubts planted by hera began to
bother emily until she asked zeus for
one favour she had zeus swear an oath on
the river styx to grant her whatever she
requested emily then told zeus she
wanted to see him in all his glory zeus
begged and pleaded for her to reconsider
but he was unsuccessful in changing her
mind and so he did as he promised
revealing his divinity no mortal was
able to look upon the true form of a god
and semilly was no exception she burst
into flames and died zeus was able to
rescue the child by sewing him into his
own thigh a child that would be born
later and one that we know as dionysus
now the stories we've heard today are by
no means every lover and affair that
took place they are the ones that were
named and have a story there are
countless nymphs and mortal women who
only appear by name and even more who
are nameless hopefully you've enjoyed
today's episode of the real housewives
of olympus
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
no
no
no
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you